Ya hace casi un año desde que hablamos, por
última vez, en este canal de la de la madre
patria del equipo de VisualPolitik: España.
Y con las elecciones generales clavadas en
pleno mes de julio se nos ocurrió que ya
tocaba volver a visitarla. Pero no, esta vez
no hablaremos ni de catástrofe económica,
ni de trenes, ni tampoco de las pensiones.
Hoy os venimos a hablar de la figura que ha
estado dominando la política española desde
el 2018. Efectivamente, queridos amigos de
VisualPolitik, os hablamos de uno de los galardonados
con nuestro antipremio al personaje político
más decepcionante en 2020 y mención especial
antipremios 2022: el presidente del gobierno
de España, Pedro Sánchez.
Si vives en España o conoces de cerca la
realidad de este país, te habrás dado cuenta
de una cosa: la sociedad está partida en
dos. Y no, no me refiere solo a la clásica
división entre la derecha y la izquierda,
sino también entre los que digamos, reprueban,
rechazan, “odian” a Pedro Sánchez y los
que le aman incondicionalmente.
De hecho, su estilo de hacer política ha
sido… ¿Cómo decirlo? Tan rompedor en España,
que incluso se le ha catalogado con nombre
propio: el “sanchismo”.
Pero ¿qué es todo esto del “sanchismo”?
Si le preguntáis a alguien de la oposición,
seguramente os diga directamente que es la
concentración de manipulación, maquiavelismo
y mentiras desenfrenadas para mantener el
poder a toda costa. Eso y también intentar
poner todas las instituciones del Estado al
servicio exclusivo del presidente.
Pero si, en cambio, le preguntáis a alguien
del Partido Socialista del que el propio Sánchez
es secretario general, os dirán que no es
más que un invento de la extrema derecha,
y que, en todo caso, es sinónimo de astucia,
tenacidad y resistencia.
Sea como sea, Pedro Sánchez no ha dejado
indiferente a nadie durante su mandato como
presidente, tanto para bien como para muy
mal. Pero, ahora bien, ¿quién es realmente
Pedro Sánchez? ¿Cómo llegó a la presidencia?
¿Qué legado deja su mandato presidencial?
¿Cómo se ha manejado Sánchez en el escenario
internacional? Pues bien, en este vídeo vamos
a responder a todas estas preguntas.
Arranquemos.
T1(SÁNCHEZ, EL PERSONAJE)
Te hago una pregunta: ¿Sabes quien es Pedro
Sánchez? Sí, vale, el actual presidente
de España. Pero, no, me refiero: ¿Sabes
algo de su vida aparte de eso?
Es curioso, porque, aunque Sánchez ha recibido
durísimas críticas, nunca se ha hablado
demasiado de su vida anterior. Algo bastante
inusual.
(Pedro Sánchez Pérez-Castejón, es natural
de Madrid e hijo de una abogada y un economista.
Quizás por eso siguió los pasos de su padre
hasta llegar a convertirse en doctor en 2012.
Y no, aquí no hablaremos de su polémica
tesis. Pero si algo está claro es que la
economía nunca ha sido su pasión. Algo muy
diferente a lo que podemos decir de la política.
En 1993, con tan solo 21 años, se afilió
al partido al que también estaba afiliado
su padre, el Partido Socialista Obrero Español,
el PSOE. Dio sus propios pasos en política,
a finales de los años 90, primero como asesor
de la europarlamentaria socialista Bárbara
Dührkop y más tarde como miembro del gabinete
del alto representante de la ONU en Bosnia,
el español Carlos Westendorp [véstendorp],
durante la guerra de los Balcanes,
Poco después, en 2004, se convirtió en concejal
del Ayuntamiento de Madrid. Y a partir de
entonces su carrera fue un no parar: en 2009
entró al Congreso de los Diputados y en 2014
ya se convirtió en secretario general del
PSOE.)
Sin embargo, como cabeza del PSOE, sus inicios
no fueron, en ningún caso, alentadores. De
hecho, perdió dos elecciones generales entre
2015 y 2016. Y de hecho ese último año las
presiones internas le obligaron a dimitir.
Sin embargo, en 2017 volvió a ganar las primarias
para convertirse, otra vez y con la mayor
del aparato de su propio partido en contra,
en secretario general.
Y, por fin, en 2018, Sánchez se convirtió
en presidente de España. Pero, para los que
nos estéis viendo desde España, si recordáis
bien, no fue por unas elecciones.
N1(Pedro Sánchez, presidente del Gobierno
tras ganar la moción de censura a Rajoy.
El País)
Efectivamente, Sánchez llegó al poder gracias
a la primera moción de censura exitosa desde
la llegada de la democracia moderna a España.
Eso sí, en 2019 hubo otra vez elecciones
y ahí, Sánchez fue el candidato más votado…
Aunque sin mayoría absoluta. Lo que le llevo
a formar el primer gobierno de coalición
de la democracia moderna en España. Lo hizo
con la formación de extrema izquierda de
Pablo Iglesias: Unidas Podemos.
Comenzó entonces una de las legislaturas
más difíciles, polémicas, controvertidas
y hostiles que podamos recordar. Una legislatura
que ha sido toda una trituradora política:
Albert Rivera, Ciudadanos, Pablo Iglesias,
Pablo Casado… Y no solo eso, durante los
últimos años para la mitad de España, Sánchez
se ha convertido en algo así como la encarnación
del mismísimo demonio.
Pero… Un momento, porque este vídeo no
va de Sánchez, sino de su política exterior.
Pues bien, a grandes rasgos, si tuviéramos
que etiquetar a este presidente, diríamos
dos cosas: multilateralista y europeísta.
Algo que, la verdad, no supone ninguna novedad.
Todos los presidentes del gobierno de España
desde la llegada de la democracia han seguido
prácticamente esa misma línea.
C1“(La Unión Europea) es una realidad que
hemos construido varias generaciones de europeos,
que ha dado grandes resultados y que queremos
que compartan con cada vez mayor intensidad
las generaciones venideras” – Mariano
Rajoy, expresidente de España (2011-2018).
Claro que, un momento, porque la etapa de
Sánchez ha ido mucho más allá.
Así que la pregunta es: ¿Cuál ha sido realmente
la apuesta internacional de Pedro Sánchez?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T2(DE POCAS LUCES Y MUCHAS SOMBRAS)
A ver, si hay algo que se le tiene que reconocer
no solo a Sánchez, sino a la mayoría de
líderes mundiales, es que estos últimos
años no han sido nada fáciles:
La toma de Hong Kong en 2019, la pandemia
en 2020, la caída de Kabul en 2021, la invasión
rusa de Ucrania en 2022, la crisis energética,
la crisis de inflación… No hablamos precisamente
de un camino de rosas.
Aún así, Sánchez ha logrado cosechar algunos,
digamos, más o menos éxitos a nivel internacional.
Por ejemplo, logró que la cumbre de la OTAN
en 2022 se celebrara en Madrid a finales del
mes de junio. Dada la guerra de Ucrania fue
una cumbre absolutamente crucial. En esa cumbre
se acordó la estrategia en Ucrania, la adhesión
de Suecia y de Finlandia y también se aprobó
un nuevo “concepto estratégico” para
el futuro de la OTAN. Es decir, el documento
esencial marca los objetivos compartidos por
sus miembros.
Y oye, esa cumbre se celebró en Madrid.
Pero eso no es todo. Sánchez también se
reunió en marzo de este mismo año con Xi
Jinping en China. Lo hizo con motivo del 50
aniversario del reconocimiento de España
al gigante asiático. Y bueno, se cerraron
algunos acuerdos y dado el contexto internacional,
la reunión fortaleció la imagen de España
como actor influyente en la Unión Europea
más hostil hacia China que podamos recordar.
Y bueno, también podríamos poner sobre la
mesa algunos logros en sus negociaciones en
Europa. Por ejemplo, convertirse en uno de
los mayores receptores de los fondos Next
Generation o conseguir prácticamente carta
blanca para hacer y deshacer sin que Bruselas
se entrometa demasiado. Las relaciones de
Sánchez y la presidenta de la Comisión Europea
Ursula von der Leyen han sido particularmente
buenas.
Sin embargo, lo cierto es que no hay mucho
más. Siento decirlo, pero tal y como ha ocurrido
con la política nacional, el historial de
Sánchez tiene más sombras que luces.
N2(Alemania deja fuera a España del escudo
antimisiles europeo. El Independiente)
Dicho de otra forma, que España, a pesar
de ser la 4ª economía más grande de toda
la Unión Europea, ha quedado excluida de
varios proyectos en los que participan sus
socios comunitarios.
Y luego tenemos el caso de Ucrania. Sí, es
cierto, tal y como hicieron el resto de los
líderes de occidente, Sánchez no tardó
en condenar la invasión.
Y, es verdad, España ha contribuido a los
esfuerzos occidentales: por ejemplo, ha reforzado
las posiciones de la OTAN mandando cazas Eurofighter
y F-18 a la frontera con Rusia, en Bulgaria
y en Lituania; ha mandado a Ucrania cascos,
vehículos blindados, artillería de 155 milímetros,
uniformes de invierno e, incluso, 10 Leopards
2.
Ha aceptado a miles de refugiados ucranianos
y, para diciembre de 2022, se habían invertido
282 millones de euros en el Fondo Europeo
para la Paz que está ayudando a financiar
los esfuerzos bélicos de Ucrania.
Pero ¿creéis que son aportaciones sustanciales?
Pues nada más lejos de la realidad:
N4(5 de marzo de 2023: España, el país occidental
que menos ha apoyado militar y económicamente
a Ucrania. En el primer año de conflicto
las entregas bilaterales apenas llegan al
0.03% del PIB. El Mundo)
Sánchez se llena la boca hablando de Ucrania.
Lo hace incluso en Kiev, pero a la hora de
la verdad nada de nada. O para ser justos,
más bien casi nada. Y no hablemos ya de la
ayuda estrictamente militar. Esta era la situación
a comienzos del 2023.
Pese a su tamaño, España no estaba ni entre
los 10 mayores contribuyentes en términos
absolutos. En términos de PIB, de hecho,
ocupaba uno de los últimos puestos.
Y aunque en 2023 la cosa mejoró marginalmente,
por ejemplo, con la entrega de los Leopards,
lo cierto es que España está en una reñida
lucha con Macron por ser los primeros por
la cola. Fijaos que ocurre cuando tenemos
en cuenta todas las ayudas a Ucrania.
Y no
se trata solo de la ayuda. En general, el
Gobierno de Sánchez ha hecho que el papel
de España en uno de los conflictos más importantes
de este siglo sea más bien poco o nada relevante.
Claro que esto no se compara ni mucho menos
a uno de los movimientos más controvertidos
de la política exterior española en toda
la etapa democrática.
¿De qué estoy hablando? Pues… Atentos.
T3 (¿QUÉ LE DEBE EL PSOE A MARRUECOS?)
En marzo de 2022 nos encontramos con uno de
los vuelcos más importantes de la política
exterior española:
N5(Pedro Sánchez cede ante Marruecos y reconoce
el plan de “autonomía para el Sáhara”
que exigía Rabat. El presidente envía una
carta al rey Mohamed VI para admitir que este
proyecto es “la base más seria, realista
y creíble” para resolver el conflicto:
El Español)
Efectivamente, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
por primera vez un gobierno español reconoció
las aspiraciones marroquíes sobre el Sáhara
Occidental. Fue algo que Sánchez hizo de
forma unilateral, sin contar siquiera con
el líder de la oposición. Sobre la situación
de España y el Sahara ya hicimos aquí en
VisualPolitik un vídeo que os dejo en la
descripción.
El caso es que eso no es todo. Además, esta
decisión entró en conflicto con los intereses
de otro socio principal de España: Argelia.
Y, os preguntaréis, ¿qué importa lo que
piensa Argelia? Pues importa, y mucho.
(Veréis, desde que se declararon independientes,
los conflictos y tensiones entre Argelia y
Marruecos no han parado: los choques, las
escaramuzas, los enfrentamientos y las peleas
diplomáticas han estado a la orden del día.
Hablamos de dos países que básicamente no
se soportan.
Y os estaréis preguntando: ¿a qué viene
tanto conflicto entre ellos? La respuesta
es muy simple: el poder. Ambos países están
luchando por convertirse en la principal potencia
del norte de África, y en esa pugna todo
vale.)
De esta forma, cuando Marruecos mostró su
apoyo a los secesionistas de la región de
La Cabilia, en Argelia, y tras descubrirse
que más de 6.000 teléfonos de altos cargos
políticos habían sido espiados desde Marruecos
con el software israelí Pegasus, Argelia
decidió romper toda relación diplomática
con su vecino hace dos años. Y, no solo eso,
cerró todo su espacio aéreo para vuelos
procedentes de Marruecos tanto civiles como
militares. Sin embargo, ese no fue el golpe
más duro de este tira y afloja:
N6(Argelia corta el mayor de sus gasoductos
con España por la crisis con Marruecos. El
presidente argelino, Abdelmayid Tebún, confirma
la rescisión del contrato a causa de las
“prácticas hostiles” de Rabat hacia Argel.
El País)
Efectivamente, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
Argelia, una de las mayores potencias gasísticas
de África, cortó de repente el gasoducto
Magreb-Europa que llegaba hasta España cruzando
por Marruecos.
Eso le supuso un duro golpe a Marruecos, que
de repente dejó de recibir gas y también
los derechos de tránsito. Pero ¿sabéis
a quién más le afectó gravemente?
Exacto, a España, que pasó a contar solamente
con el gasoducto Medgaz que la conecta directamente
a Argelia. Dicho de otra forma, España sufrió
un duro golpe a su seguridad energética.
Pero, atentos, porque la situación iba a
empeorar aún más.
(Ante semejante escenario, Sánchez se decantó
totalmente por Marruecos: cesó a su ministra
de exteriores, González Laya solo una semana
después de que Rabat lo exigiera y aceptó
el plan del gobierno marroquí para el antiguo
territorio español.
Pues bien, el caso es que el reconocimiento
de las pretensiones marroquíes sobre el Sáhara
Occidental por parte de Sánchez no hizo más
que enfurecer a Argelia. Y es que hay que
tener en cuenta que, desde que España abandonó
el Sáhara en 1975 y Marruecos la colonizó
con la famosa Marcha Verde, Argelia ha acogido
a miles de refugiados saharauis y ha apoyado
activamente al Frente Polisario, el principal
movimiento de liberación del Sáhara Occidental.)
Es decir, que España perdió su principal
baza estratégica de presión a Marruecos,
se desentendió de un compromiso histórico
y encima se pegó con Argelia, su principal
suministrador de gas en medio de una crisis
energética.
N7(6 octubre de 2022: Argelia encarece el
precio del gas que envía a España en su
revisión del contrato con Naturgy para 2022,
que sigue negociando para 2023. 20 Minutos)
Además, desde entonces, Argelia ha interrumpido
buena parte del comercio bilateral entre los
dos países, además de priorizar a países
europeos como Italia respecto a España para
todo tipo de proyectos de futuro.
De hecho, el movimiento de Sánchez no podía
haberse dado en un peor momento. Pensadlo
bien, en un escenario en que la seguridad
energética estaba pendiente de un hilo tras
el bloqueo a Rusia, España se podía haber
convertido en uno de los actores claves del
suministro energético de Europa. Una posición
que ocupará Italia.
Y ya sé lo que os estaréis preguntando:
¿Qué saca España de semejante cambio? Pues
lo cierto es que no está nada claro. El beneficio
no parece verse por ninguna parte. De hecho,
este histórico movimiento ni siquiera ha
hecho que Marruecos deje de reclamar Ceuta
y Melilla.
N8(27 de mayo de 2023: Rabat se refiere a
Ceuta y Melilla como “ciudades marroquíes”
en un escrito de censura contra un vicepresidente
de la Comisión Europea. El País)
Hay quien dice que fue una forma de relajar
unas tensiones con Marruecos que estaban peor
que nunca. Hay quien dice que también tuvo
que ver con este terrible incidente que ocurrió
apenas unas semanas antes del cambio de postura:
N9(Investigación BBC: cómo la policía española
vio y no impidió que decenas de migrantes
murieran en su frontera con Marruecos (el
24 de junio de 2022). BBC)
N10(La ONU insta a España y Marruecos a investigar
las muertes en la frontera de Melilla. El
País)
N11(Los supervivientes del salto de Melilla
denuncian que la Guardia Civil los golpeó
y devolvió a Marruecos a personas heridas.
El Diario)
Y otros apuntan a otro tipo de factores más
o menos sospechosos. Por ejemplo, que Marruecos
hubiera usado el sistema Pegasus para espiar
al propio Sánchez o a miembros de su gobierno.
Así se podrían haber enterado de que España
le estaba prestando atención médica al líder
del Frente Polisario, Brahim Ghali. Algo que
irritó sobremanera a Marruecos.
Pero sea como sea, el caso es que cada día
que pasa, el cambio de postura de Sánchez
parece uno de los mayores errores que se recuerdan.
Desde un punto de vista de la RealPolitik
el Sahara y la relación con Argelia eran
las dos grandes bazas para, llegado el caso,
presionar a Marruecos. Ahora eso es historia.
Ya veis, queridos seguidores de VisualPolitik,
la presidencia de Pedro Sánchez no ha estado
exenta de polémicas, tanto internas como
externas. Y, siendo honestos, no podemos decir
que desde el punto de vista de la política
exterior, Sánchez haya dejado a España en
una posición mejor que cuando llegó.
En otras palabras, que España sigue siendo
en el panorama internacional tan insignificante,
si no más como cuando llegó a la Moncloa.
Pero llegados hasta aquí turno para ti: ¿creéis
que España es más relevante en el plano
internacional hoy que hace 10 años? ¿Cómo
valoráis el movimiento de Sánchez sobre
Marruecos?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Por cierto, en nuestro canal hermano VisualEconomik,
estamos publicando varios vídeos especiales
sobre la situación económica de España.
Estamos desmontando algunos mitos y, también,
os vamos a contar en dos vídeos especiales
cuáles son los mayores retos a los que se
enfrenta España. Os dejo algunos enlaces
en la descripción.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí en VisualPolitik
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así
que suscribíos a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado este vídeo,
dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el próximo. Un
saludo y hasta pronto.